Paris and Brussels showed this very
clearly information exchange is our
Achilles he'll report in un papel travel
la lucha con solitary Braille accra del
tragic adista por ello reglamento lado
terada mejor es capaz edades instrumento
znac invito awesome jansen van Shaun
Marsh on danke pharmacol or Nazi against
leash up kadazan Sheng's taught maybe
Schengen is not dead yet but it's
certainly on life support Dublin
regulation is the cornerstone of the
European asylum system this is the time
to once and for all get it right juicy
global no favor hablas echo
trivialization avisa me panabaka Bo Paul
families kiss passage Oreo cookie mr.
Erdogan makes it known that if the
European Parliament takes the wrong
decision that he will let the refugees
travel to Europe I mean that is
blackmail in my book and why is Europe
open to blackmail because we are weak
and divided aggressor dozy japako be
declared asleep a tener en parte que
significa t do shimakaze awesome a newt
danielle maye Papa uncle Moshe linda y
le capacity Darcy small okay sonal a tus
canoe depot say obey yo habia comido
deploy Younker poor fella favor over
geico Kristianstad pacifism politically
prasad greenland key Charlotte
distinguish me clip on clothes on
Dusty's let's TR n fallow a nice Yaffe
Greenland VAR / may problema SI chiama
fondo monetary o internatio nuh I
problemas or olestra misty k Noonan no
me di una visión venda cattiva vogliono
pune real igreja it is undeniable that
china is not a market economy by any
standards the question of crimson market
economy status to china is one of
unprecedented political significance not
only will it affect you trade but
deriving from it jobs and growth as well
wages and environmental standards are
lower in China than they are in the EU
actually importers in Europe benefit
from this aspect of globalization and it
can also lead to low
prices for consumers Venezuela kameena
inevitable mente Zelda's astray estamos
Alvord a del estado de una crisis
sociale y tenemos que hacer lo posible
para evitarlo ya tebe colleague nunca
lin- zeggen ah maanta resistant at side
farrago pacho quien fue a la pago para
en de novo Priya yeah indecent madera
transnational endemic aati estas best
Modell free decision on Susan I don't in
LA she now goes off Sophie own is legal
so high